okay so i am really really excited for
today's video
because it's going to be
a gambit video
a trap video
and it's going to be on an opening that
really doesn't have so much information
online very hard to find any sort of
commentary
or analysis
on this opening which i'm about to show
and if you enjoy the stafford gambit and
i'm pretty sure you're going to enjoy
the o'sullivan gambit now we'll jump
straight in the o'sullivan starts as an
alkyne's defense
uh we'll be looking from the black side
now the main reply uh for white and
alakine is to play e5
knight d5
and d4
uh we should note that if white doesn't
go into this position and maybe deviates
with a move like knight c3
or after e5 goes for c4 and
unfortunately we can't play the
o'sullivan
but uh after d4
then we are all set
to unleash the o'sullivan
which is pawn to b5 on move three
very rare and uh and tricky move um
it turns out that there's no games in
the masters database
however on leech us
there's been
about
7 500 games so apparently this is a
somewhat known opening but i want to go
ahead and break down the tricks and
traps
associated with this of course black is
gamuting the b pawn which white is very
much welcome to take and i should note
that this is an objectively dubious
opening
if white plays properly white will have
an objective advantage but that's not to
say there's a lot of ways for white to
go wrong
and stumble into
the nasty traps that black has in store
especially for unprepared players so in
in this video we're going to break down
the basic traps we'll look at what
happens when white declines the gamut
we'll look at one of the coolest opening
traps ever
not just in the sullivan but in chess in
general we're gonna see
a really really cool opening sequence
and then at the very end we'll see a
counter trap for the white side against
the o'sullivan so before we get into all
the traps analysis
i do want to thank the sponsor of
today's video
which is skillshare you probably know by
now but skillshare is an online learning
community with thousands of classes
ranging from so many different topics
including business marketing
design even lifestyle and productivity
classes
now one class that i've been taking that
i'm really enjoying so far
is called how to organize your workflow
to maximize productivity it's a class by
ali abdal who's a doctor and youtuber
and he's done an amazing job kind of
breaking down the science of
productivity and he talks a lot about
how to develop the right habits how to
become more self-aware and how to create
better systems to just live a more
productive life so if you want to get
access to this course
along with thousands of others i do have
a special offer for my subscribers the
first 1 000 people to click the link in
the video description below will get a
one month free trial to skill share so
you can start learning and exploring
everything the platform has to offer and
thanks again to skillshare for
sponsoring today's video now let's get
back to some chess
okay let's dive into some of the basic
traps of the o'sullivan
now just as a review we go into the main
line pawn b5 marks the beginning of the
o'sullivan
and just to point out uh the opening
database black scores really well in
this opening overall
almost every line there is a majority
win percentage for black
even when white accepts a gamut uh black
is winning 58 of the time
and even though stockfish won't like
this position for black giving white an
almost plus two advantage
on a practical level there is just a lot
of ways that black can get counter play
and this is one of those cases where
yeah objectively white is better but
when it comes to actual gameplay
there's a lot of positions which will
just be easier to play for black not to
mention all the tricks and traps
so we're gonna focus on the main line
which will be bishop takes b5
and here black will play pawn c5
and i'm gonna hide the notation just not
spoil anything
and
i should note the reason for giving away
the b-pawn was to bait the bishop
into an undefended square in black's
territory
and after c5 black is not only aiming to
try and tear apart like pawn center but
also has a really sly tactical threat
of playing queen a5
to attack the king and to attack the
bishop
and usually when queen a5 is played
there's a response to knight c3
but in many cases as we're going to see
knight c3 can usually be met with knight
take c3
so one of the main ways white can go
wrong here
is if white takes a pawn
green a5 is already
practically winning for black and
there's no great response to get out of
check
and save material
uh we should start by noting if knight
d2 or bishop d2 that blocks a queen from
attacking the knights and black can take
the bishop if the move pawn c3 is played
then there's a very nice line
queen takes b5
queen takes d5 looks like a fair trade
however after bishop e7
black is getting the last bite
and white is now
getting shish kebabs along the long
diagonal
and is either going to lose a queen or
if queen moves somewhere let's say queen
b3 we can trade
and then win the g2 pawn along with a
rook on h1
i should also mention if king f1 this
doesn't help because queen takes b5
comes with chuck
so white is in in big trouble after
queen a5
and if we look at the database
uh this position has been reached
over 450 times
and black is winning a very significant
percentage of the games
now i should mention the best move for
white here is to play knight d2
uh with the idea that after queen digs
b5 there's pawn to c4
with a fork winning back the piece
however black still better here after
queen c5 pawn takes d5 queen diggs d5
uh there's a double attack in the end
and uh engine will give almost minus two
in black's favor
so
going back to
this position
if d takes c5 is played queen a5 already
gives black a significant advantage
and dc5 is the third most popular move
so played a good amount of the time
another way white can go wrong is knight
f3
played
about 200 times even though there's some
some transpositions here
and after queen a5
again black is doing quite well
uh many cases white will just end up
losing the bishop like if knight c3
here's where we can take on c3
and at bc3
uh we don't want to take because then
bishop d2 defends the rook and hits the
queen but we just take on b5 and black
is up a clean piece with already a
decisive advantage
so turns out in this position white
still has the same resource
knight d2 which some people will find
and after queen digs b5 there is pawn c4
however here black can
very simply just slide back to a5 cd5
and take on d4
hitting the pawn on d5 computer gives
some kind of level equality but it's
still a very dynamic position black has
a prospect of bishop a6
to potentially disrupt white's castling
and
these pawns even though they look strong
they can be
very
easy targets for black
especially if black can keep putting up
pressure
so this pretty much covers the
the main idea of those sullivan
is when the bishop is baited to b5 we
play c5 and uh there's a lot of ways for
white to go wrong
um now i want to move on to
the o'sullivan declined and i know
there's a lot of players out there that
just have the philosophy of just don't
accept any gambit play it safe
so a lot of players will play a move
like knight f3
and this is where we can still be
aggressive and play pawn c5 and i think
it's very typical in this opening
regardless of what white plays
on move four black is very likely to
respond with c5 on the next move
so after knight of three on c5
white now has a few options which pawn
to take if we take a look at bishop
takes b5 we'll notice this is a direct
transposition from what we just saw
with a double attack
and if white takes on c5 the most common
move then black can very simply defend
the knight with pawn e6 uh while also
attacking the pawn on c5 this pawn is
not easy for white to defend note that
the knight on d5 discourages bishop e3
and also pawn b4
so it's most common for white to play
pawn c4 here
and the line i'll show is actually the
most common line that white will play
after bc4 bishop c4
we can reinforce the knight and this is
another common idea of the o'sullivan is
to get the bishop on the long diagonal
and have some really nice lasting
pressure
against white's kingside and also just
have good harmony between the bishop and
the knight and potential later for some
discoveries uh for example there's some
crazy idea later to play g5 knight f4
rook g8
and target the g pawn of course this is
just a more long-term idea if you want
to be super super aggressive in the
middle game
going forward from here most players
will castle black can regain the pawn
and most people play knight to c3
after which we can trade
trade and queen c7
and we're reaching a position where the
bishops are really really nice along
these two nice diagonals
with queen c7 we're not only pressuring
e5 which is obviously a target but we're
also pressuring the bishop on c4 which
is not defended which means we're
threatening bishop f2 and queen takes e4
so most players play bishop to b3
protecting the bishop and after knight
c6 black is already doing quite well has
a lot of nice pressure against e pawn
computer will give already a pleasant
advantage for
black
almost a one pawn advantage
despite material being equal
and if white plays the most common move
bishop f4
97 is a nice move just unleashing the
bishop and preparing to play knight g6
with all the minor pieces having
attacking potential on the king side
so that's just a quick summary of
o'sullivan declined
so now comes a time where we're gonna
see
one of the coolest traps i've ever seen
at least one of the coolest traps i've
seen in recent memory moving on to
chapter five
we are going to dive back in to the
o'sullivan accepted with bishop takes b5
and remember we play c5 preparing the
double attack against the king and
bishop and here one of the most common
moves for white is pawn c4
and if white were to play this then
they're already likely to walk into
a really really awesome trap
so i don't want to spoil things too much
so i'm going to hide the notation now
we're going to see just an incredible
sequence of moves
starting with the very surprising
pawn digs d4
the point of this move is that we are
still having the idea of queen a5
in the event of pawn takes knight
we win back the minor piece
and black is actually going to come out
ahead here if bishop d2
we take the bishop and now we're
actually threatening both pawns maybe
it's more likely for white to play queen
d2
after takes we do lose the d-pawn
however after bishop a6
black is doing really really really well
now that queen f1 is is just a hard to
stop threat
and if the knight develops to protect f1
now e2 is unguarded and queen e2 is just
checkmate
um so the best try for white hero would
be knight d2 but after the move pawn to
e6
uh white's position is already just kind
of crumbling given that the pawn is
attacked
if the pawn moves to d6
which looks a little bit troublesome for
black then there's knight c6 hitting the
queen hitting the pawn
this is not even the cool trap yet this
is just a sideline but we can see
in the opening database there have been
a handful of games that have reached
this position engine will give already
an engine is pretty savage giving
already
minus 7.4
for black i guess yeah all of white's
things are crumbling and there's still
potential for
some nastiness along the light squares
so let's go back to
the even more beautiful trap
let's say white doesn't take
the
the knight
but rather captures a pawn on d4 which
is the most common move
uh most players who who get into this
will realize that queen a5
is an idea and they'll they'll be
inclined to take it looks like white is
doing quite well has a nice center the
knight is still attacked
but here black can throw a really nice
counter punch
knight to b4
threatening the triple fork with knight
c2 it seems like black shouldn't be
causing too much headache for white
given that the knight is only piece
developed most players will respond with
knight a3 here just defending c2 but
here's where black delivers yet another
nice punch in the position queen a5
of course with the obvious
discovery threat uh black is now
threatening the discover triple fork
which would cause white a lot of misery
but black also has a really secret
threat with queen a5
most players will play bishop to d2 here
and this is where black can unleash
a really really surprising move
and i encourage those who maybe don't
see the move already to pause the video
and find the soul crushing move for
black in this position
and now i want to congratulate everyone
who found the amazing
queen takes a3
yes this is a an oh no my queen moment
but here if white just takes back
we're gonna win the queen straight back
and in the process
black has won a minor piece and just has
a decisive advantage so queen dix a3 is
a start of
what is going to
lead to even more beauty most players
here
will
play queen e4
realizing the danger and after queen e4
black is still under some pressure the
rook is now attacked the queen is still
hanging the knight is pressured
and black still has to come up with some
moves to survive
um here we can take on b2
attacking the rook
and now if white takes on eight we take
on
a1 it's a trait of rooks but black is
getting uh getting some more fun in this
position if king e2 we take on e5
attacking the king defending the knight
black is already having a decisive
advantage so
going back here most players will play
rook to b1
and it still looks like black is under
some pressure
the queen's attacked the rook is
attacked on the a8
um and here there's a couple winning
moves for black
when i give this position to most people
they'll say knight c2 which is actually
the easier move to find but it's not the
absolute best move
uh knight c2 the position can still get
murky after king e2
takes takes it's still a bit of a mess
so rather than knight c2 there's a
really aesthetic way
for black to completely solve all of the
problems in the position
and just wind up up material
and that move is queen takes e5
leveraging yet another potential fork in
the position
this time if queen takes queen
there is knight to d3 black wins back
the queen
and if we count material black is up a
knight and a pawn and just has a winning
position
so this is just a really beautiful
sequence if we see
just kind of a fast motion replay
even starting with pawn digs d4
surprising move
knight before threatening the fork
between a5 threatening the discover
triple fork
and then the queen goes on their journey
to take on a3
take on b2 and then to take on e5
not every day you see the queen going on
a path like this
um sacrificing itself multiple times
but in every case the tactics work out
for black
and this is winning
congratulations to the
the five players who have reached this
position i guess four players have
actually converted this position as
black
but it's a nice one to know and it's one
that is definitely on my bucket list
i hope to achieve some day
in life
so going back i do want to be thorough
here and just point out a few things
according to the engine
after
knight a3
it turns out the best move is actually
a6 now this doesn't lead to the same
amount of beauty but it does give black
a better position because after bishop
a4 queen a5 is a more simple double
attack and black is winning material
here
the actual problem with queen a5
immediately is white has queen e4
and surprisingly
black is actually worse here even though
there's a lot of discoveries computer
gives a plus for white now no one has
ever found the move queen e4 so i don't
think it's something to worry about
and i could say that if i get this
position i would be playing queen a5
going for the the really fancy
uh walk of the queen
to win all of white's material so i
really hope those watching have enjoyed
this this trap and maybe can use it in
in some of their own games
now i do want to finish the video with
one counter trap against the sullivan
we're gonna move on to chapter six
and look at what happens when white is
really well prepared so let's get to our
main position
here white will accept the gamut
and after pawn c5
let's imagine you are playing against
o'sullivan you want to trap black in
this case the move to play is bishop to
c4
which is actually a nice move it gets
the bishop out of the potential danger
of queen a5 it also keeps initiative
against the knight
and here
a lot of o'sullivan players will be
inclined to take on d4
using the idea that we've seen multiple
times so far
is if bishop takes d5
there's queen a5 and it looks like black
will just be winning back material
however in this position white has an
amazing way
to stay up material
and it starts with a surprising move
knight c3
offering the knights
basically for free let's say black takes
it now in this position
it looks like white
can snag the rook
however
that would just end tragically after
pawn takes b2
bishop d2 black can promote the queen
win back the rook black now temporarily
has two queens on the board
and whichever queen is taken the other
queen will survive
and black is doing completely fine here
a2 will hang in some variations
um so going back to this position
this is white to move and win
so i don't want to give too many clues
but feel free to pause the video and try
and find
the best move for white and the only
winning move for white in this position
okay so the key to winning this position
as white
is to defend against the threat
of pawn digs b2
while not giving black time to actually
save the rook
for example if we play a move like pawn
b3 that gives black time to play knight
c6 and black is okay
so the best move to play in this
position is amazing pawn to b4
hitting the queen the rook is still
hanging
and white is going to be
up
a lot of material at the end of this and
i should note there's no on passant here
on passant doesn't work when you have a
pawn on the third rank
if you're confused you can google on
passant but uh yeah white is is winning
here
and this means that black should not
enter this line
uh if you encounter bishop c4
the better move to play is just bishop
e7
and you can still treat this as a gambit
style position
where you have the bishop on the long
diagonal targeting g2 very often black
can develop with e6 knight c6 or still
queen a5 potential
and
the game can be very much of a fight
from here
so
i tried to be thorough with with kind of
covering the critical lines
for those that have questions leave them
below
and i'll try and answer as many as i can
also feel free to study on your own in
the leachat study i'll be leaving a link
so you'll have this full analysis
along with all the annotated chapters
you can use opening explorer you can use
stockfish
and that's just an easy way to perhaps
answer
some of your your questions immediately
but yeah i really hope you enjoyed this
video i know it's a different sort of
opening i've been wanting to make
content on this opening for a while
and if there's any openings that you'd
like to see me cover in future videos
feel free to leave suggestions below
and i'll see you in the next video